now welcome to this video playing our
chief an IM from hmm yeah yeah yeah
kuwait united arab emirates I really
should look right up okay while he's
playing some wacky gambit from the
England gambit I'm not taking the porn
I'm just developing seems to be wiser I
guess okay I can take yeah well it's
just upon any way for no compensation
let's go here maybe it goes to 95 and I
can take I cannot take okay I cannot
take but almost okay Queen to e7 hmm
yeah probably going for quick long
castle okay mom he's got knight Knight
e5 coming I have this check on f5 and 26
available not great but can do that it's
still just a pawn and um yeah this would
be nice but have Queen a fast check
winning this piece yeah this was a
really weird game I mean it's naive but
well you never know some some black
resigned and it's check let's check this
NASA site cannot say that I know this is
this person yeah well you never know
there are some international masters
that got they got the title by not
really completing the norms and the
rating and so on but by winning junior
championships there are some rules to
get to those titles by winning for a
continental junior championships and
sometime sometimes this is relatively
easy to do I mean the winning the I
don't know under 16 African Championship
you some of those guys really only have
two thousand and it's a much more
difficult to do so in Europe to win a
European continental junior you need to
be in yeah very often you need to be at
least an i am one in in Asia or Africa
well I know that that this is asia not
not africa but in Asia especially in
former times it was all so much easier
to do yeah bid over
strophe this this game and opening
opening disaster I can briefly look at
this i mean the eggnog gambit is really
completely incorrect just just a pound
for nothing if black plays Queenie seven
trying to get it back you have many ways
to to to play one good way amongst
others is some is 93 this is what i
usually do what you need to be cautious
about is this last thing this this would
old trap that funny enough wins for
black so quite quite crazy this is
winning for black it's overloaded on c2
and Quincy to checkmate is this funky
made on c1 this is the the only real
idea of the Anglin gambit and 11 good
way to play is 93 this is what I usually
do night the night takes and 95 texas
takes Queen back Bishop f4 t-64 this is
what I usually play it it's probably not
the refutation but it gives you a free
game with Queen Queen d2 and long
castles if I never really had time to
look look to look it up maybe search for
something better but this is a good way
to play while he played f6 and here you
really shouldn't take I mean you can
it's a silly porn and so on but you
don't have this natural move before
available now and you can just play here
and how is he he didn't take but how is
he ever going to to develop it's very
difficult this is compared comparable to
play f5 against the Italian game which I
sometimes play in one minute chess it
for fun but then it's really not not
playable here and well this I can also
take now here also
with Bishop c4 coming it's simply an
incorrect opening alright thanks for
watching